President Trump is giving a shout-out to
Mexico tonight he's crediting officials
there with breaking up a caravan of
Central Americans aiming to cross into
the u.s. at the Mexican border this
comes as the president's plan to put
National Guard troops on that border is
scrutinized both tactically and
politically chief White House
correspondent John Roberts starts us off
tonight
he can jump good evening to you Brad
there is plenty of criticism tonight for
the president's plan to put narshe
National Guard troops on the border
people thinking that it's unnecessary
and way too expensive but there are also
plenty of people who are applauding the
president's decision in West Virginia to
promote his tax cut president Trump
turned his eyes southward explaining why
he's calling out the National Guard to
secure the border
we're working out systems now and we
called out the National Guard we're
doing a real job but I'll tell you what
the laws of this country have to be
strengthened and tough enough Customs
and Border Protection is working up
recommendations to the Department of
Defense for troop deployments the DoD
will approach governor's from four
border states to see if they can fulfill
the mission with their own troops if not
the Pentagon will likely approach other
states to fill in the blanks Texas New
Mexico and Arizona welcomed the idea of
mobilizing the guards unclear at this
point is whether California Governor
Jerry Brown will agree to send his
state's troops to the border certainly
his relationship with President Trump on
immigration is troubled the grounds done
a very poor job running California but
DHS secretary Kirsten Nielsen says talks
with Brown continue he has
seen this happened before and he had
seen it happen well what thrust this
issue to the forefront was reports of a
caravan of more than a thousand Central
American migrants headed for the US
border President Trump today praised
Mexico for as he claimed breaking up the
caravan his numbers were overinflated
Mexico's been pretty good they were very
good to us yesterday because you know
they had the caravan of thousands of
people coming up from Honduras thousands
of people and we have very weak laws
because of the Democrats it was the
president's fourth visit to West
Virginia State he won by nearly 40
points and a promise to bring back jobs
he found a friendly audience for his
tough stance against China and his
proposed tariffs on 60 billion dollars
worth of Chinese goods you have to go
after the people that aren't treating
you right and in many respects I think
we're gonna have a fantastic
relationship long-term with China but we
have to get this straightened out we
have to have some balance many
industries are hyperventilating at the
prospect of retaliatory tariffs
announced yesterday by China against us
Goods and whether it could set off a
debilitating trade war so the White
House again today dispatched the new
chief economic adviser to tell American
producers to just exhale both countries
have just proposed tariff there's
nothing in that let's not jump to
present president Trump is using the
economic argument as a cudgel against
West Virginia Democratic Senator Joe
Manchin up for re-election in November
the president today blaming Manchin for
everything but the weather Joe he voted
against no it was bad I thought it would
be helpful but he votes against
everything and he voted against our tax
cuts and it was bad and he voted he also
voted against medical help and health
care and he does other things that I
don't like I'll be honest with you well
the plan for deploying troops to the
border is still being finalized
President Trump on Air Force One on the
way back from West Virginia this
afternoon said he'd like to put between
two and four thousand troops on the
border and he would like a substantial
number of those troops to stay there
until the wall is built Brett John
Roberts live in the North Lawn John
thanks